at a special meeting of Parliament's
Budget Committee familiar faces exchange
greetings and for some of those catching
up with colleagues after the elections
it would be one of their final
appearances with the EU nao on more
stable ground the Commission unveiled
its draft proposal for the e use 142
billion euro budget for 2015 the focus
was on continued growth and honoring
commitments the initial reaction by M
eps was positive it is in line what we
have expected from Commissioner 11 those
keys which is support the growth
employment and jobs as well as the
further a direction of the
administrative costs seem pretty
reasonable and logical but the big issue
with the budget 2015 is to address a
growing problem an almost 4 billion
backlog of payments since 2013 the gap
has been widening between what the EU
says it will pledge its money to and
what in fact gives its money to to stop
this rolling over into the next
financial year the Commissioner proposed
using contingency margins to help
balance the books but according to the
author of Parliament's report on the
budget and paid built in fact totals in
24 billion euros with this contingency
imagine if we approve it we can smooth
the situation and maybe we can ASSU the
payments for two three four months but
we are not going to finish the year in a
good situation and even the Commissioner
had hard words for member states at
least some Member States tend to forget
but there are financial implications of
political decisions here is a problem
for several years where our financial
implications of political decisions if
we promised we should deliver em ep's
are expected to approve the commission's
proposal but for some outgoing any Peas
at the meeting they feared a mess ahead
for the incoming Parliament